a menos de una semana de las elecciones
en chile se realizó el último debate
electoral el más tenso de los comicios
chilenos en el foco el candidato de
ultraderecha josé antonio kast por
blanquear la dictadura de augusto
pinochet y posicionarse en contra del
aborto y el matrimonio igualitario no
sólo tenemos que dejar de hablar del
pasado ya y josean pero casas bien
directamente citar a pinochet en el
siglo 21 como ejemplo de democracia una
elección competida dictadura me parece
un error durante las casi tres horas de
debate se abordaron temas clave como la
gobernabilidad la seguridad pública y el
medio ambiente allí seis de los siete
candidatos presidenciales quemaron su
último cartucho para convencer a la
población y mientras la popularidad de
jose k se desplomó la de su principal
contrincante el diputado de izquierda a
gabriel boric subió a ésta empatarlo
como favorito dimos cuenta de que somos
una candidatura
se hace cargo de los cambios y de las
demandas que está exigiendo el pueblo de
chile y que somos capaces de llevarla
adelante con gobernabilidad con
gradualidad con mucha convicción junto a
la presidencia los comicios del domingo
también decidieran los diputados
senadores y consejeros regionales
ninguno de los competidores cuenta con
más del 30 por ciento del apoyo de la
población en las encuestas y el ganador
deberá enfrentar una posible nueva
constitución la creciente inflación y la
crisis social ahora los casi 15 millones
de chilenos que están llamados a las
urnas decidirán quién sucederá a
sebastián piñera al frente del país